[Music]
let's turn now to bachelor in paradise
because tonight is the night so how much
of what happened between tomorrow and
Corinne in the pool will we see well one
thing's for certain de Mario was ready
to show the taste et has learned not
everything that went down between
Khurana Demario and Paradise will end up
on TV a source tells us the hook-up
won't be shown but the aftermath will
play out with intense detail it was
confusing so trust me it needs to all
play out today eg on lines lauren zima
spoke with cast member derik path but
was in paradise when it all went down
and has been an early version off
night's episode you're gonna see plenty
of Qurna tomorrow you know talking with
each other
drinking with each other the ark also
says at one point quran tried to make a
move on him
Curren jumped on me and i avoided making
out with there we're told neither Fran
or Demario have seen tonight's episode
and Derek says he plans to watch it with
tomorrow
how many hookups will we see in the
premiere oh geez do we need to count
I don't remember I'm sorry
[Music]
you